you try and get a kid to watch baseball
or even boxing for that matter
really oh yeah dylan will watch boxing i
can't get him to watch baseball can you
watch baseball boxing the watch a little
bit but unless it's like anthony joshua
or deante wilder they're not into it got
it yeah ufc the watch yeah did you ever
do you ever show them your fights oh
yeah yeah what do they think yeah i mean
he loves it he says he wants to be he
does jiu jitsu now nice he did i
actually picked up my black belt because
of him because i've been a black belt
for years but i've never had the actual
black belt and i think i never want to
lie to my son so i saw he used to beg me
to do jitsu so i drive him this jiu
jitsu place
and it's like probably day four of him
competing there and you know he's good
at athletic and so
he we walk in there and you know his
coaches have black belt but you know
they're like
like 300 pound guy they're not in great
shape but they have black belts
and there's also there chris barley
comes in all right we're going to learn
about garage there was a guy named roy
nelson who was yeah i fought him
nightmare great guy
great fighter but he uh back to the
point though is again at black belt
there's different levels of black belts
there's like there could be a black belt
from one school there could be a another
black belt in there and different
standards is what you're saying so my
son goes dad you have a black belt i go
dude you've seen my what do you think
black belt yeah i've submitted a guy in
the ufc man the first anaconda joke ever
in the heavyweight division yeah i'm a
black belt yes oh can we show me your
black bat at home like
what i don't have like physical
but i got it i know he's got a black
yeah then he goes could you beat them up
like are you [ __ ] me dude
them
oh my god so we got in the car i called
my coach i talked in like five years i'm
all east side hey coach you still have
that black belt for me he's like we've
been waiting for you to pick it up i go
i'm booking my [ __ ] ticket now i'll
be there friday so me and my son fly
down the demo he's five he's five flew
down to denver he came into the school
and they had to roll with all the black
belts and they gave me my black yeah
yeah i took the belt off and there's
your black belt
at five previously
and what's his tiger tiger by the way is
he big like you is he a big kid yeah
okay so is it like 99 percentile type of
kid yeah five and two you said five and
two what's the two year old bruiser yeah
his name is bruiser no no he's his
name's boston yeah boston the bruiser
wow why boss
well i don't know sorry different just
different names we named the kid
brooklyn yeah so exactly it's not like
he he probably goes to uh before
christmas where he says you know in our
family dad named us after the city they
conceived us orlando
so i'm going to ask you ask you the same
question i asked pat man it's a tough
question to think about but when you're
when you're coming up like you said you
you got tough because of your
environment right like you had to you
had an environment where you had to
develop personality you had to develop
skill sets right now you're growing up
you got rich kids now your kids are
growing up rich your kids are growing up
in calabasas yeah la kids yep they're
[ __ ] so here's the thing very similar
to a roll roll but this is the thing
right it's like
you want to give your kids everything
that you never had sure but then you're
going to turn them into everything that
you never were correct so i mean what do
you do to make sure sports sports
because there's no
the sports that'll humble him like he
they he doesn't have to go pro in sports
i'm not like that overbearing dad but
he's gonna have to play sports because
that teaches them respect
humility
toughness when you're gonna do something
like uh jiu jitsu you're gonna put him
in some kind of mma some kind of mix
four times a week he does jitsu he does
soccer he's into everything yeah so the
culture now my kids go to the bar jiu
jitsu right here and you go there i
gotta tell you man this is good for kids
like i didn't grow up with that so i'm
not like somebody that went to it but
i'm watching how they talk to hey you
know they're trying to discipline them
it's not like it's okay it's not one of
those environments it's pretty like
pretty strong if it's a good gym
i think there's a lot of benefits to it
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you